Donald Trump announced yesterday in a
sick and disgusting video that on day
one of his next presidency if he is to
get one he will violate the constitution
of the United States Trump loves the
Constitution just like he loves American
flags and Law and Order and all of these
different things Trump loves the
Constitution and many of his followers
see it almost like a sacred religious
document and yet Trump says on day one
of his presidency if he is inaugurated
in January of 2025 he will sign an
executive order ending Birthright
citizenship as guaranteed by the 14th
Amendment to the Constitution of the
United States here is Donald Trump
looking admittedly a little confused not
clear he knows where he is or what he's
saying uh take a listen to what he says
plan to secure the border on day one
of my new chairman office I will sign an
executive order making clear to federal
agencies that under the correct
interpretation of the law
going forward the future children of
illegal aliens will not receive
automatic U.S citizenship yeah now he
says there according to some
interpretations of the law if you can
find me serious legal experts who
believe that Birthright citizenship
could be denied as written in the 14th
Amendment please send me that because
all of the research I did this morning
matches up with my uh prior discussions
with legal experts on the matter which
is it is very clearly part of the 14th
Amendment now I want to focus in on one
particular aspect of this the right
Wingers cheerleading this idea and
Birthright citizenship and anchor babies
as they love to call them those right
Wingers should be very careful about the
unintended consequences that Trump
trying to do this could have first of
all
it does appear it would violate the
constitution and the Supreme Court
precedent which established that there
is a fundamental right to citizenship if
born in the United States
right-wingers claim to worship that
document as a religious text and indeed
it appears as though this is a
fundamental right
if they were to attempt this it would be
potentially years and years and years of
legal
conundra we might call it and in the
immediate it would much more quickly
increase the undocumented population in
the United States which they claim to
want to reduce this is a really
important thing if Trump ends Birthright
citizenship going forward then you are
going to have a situation where babies
will be born here
will immediately be undocumented
presumably subject to deportation and it
will so instantly clog up and gum up
immigration processes that because you
will all of a sudden see authorities
tied up with looking at deporting
newborn babies you actually might you
know they say that we really care about
criminal aliens the people committing
crimes Etc to the extent that they exist
and they do to a degree but just not to
the degree that Donald Trump says you
are going to get in the way
of actually locating and deporting those
individuals who are only not only
undocumented but have committed uh
crimes because you are going to be
focusing on trying to deport newborn
babies they are going to make the
problem they want to fix worse secondly
it will impact the American economy it
will reduce the labor force it will
reduce the tax base it will reduce
consumer Demand by just getting rid of
people and their families even if
they're babies and they're not spending
their own money you are going to push
them as well as potentially parents out
of the United States you will reduce the
tax base reduce the labor force and
reduce consumer demand that's not good
for the economy years of legal
challenges will also come with them
we'll bring with them huge financial
costs these claim to be fiscal
conservatives but of course it will be
extraordinarily expensive and it will
destroy International image of the
United States now that's not anything
new you might remember that Gallup
Global surveys about global opinion
about the the United States
bottomed out when Trump was president
has fortunately started to recover since
Joe Biden became president but again the
United States for all of our faults the
United States has been seen
generally not every part of the United
States but generally the United States
has been seen as a nation that Embraces
immigrants offers opportunity to those
born within its borders and if you end
Birthright citizenship particularly in
this vindictive way you're going to
tarnish that image and then that will
make it more difficult to continue uh
having the exact same relationships
diplomatically with our long-term allies
there will be other countries affected
by the policy change on and on and on
and there are question marks as to what
such a decision by Trump would do to
National Security efforts and what I
mean by that is that Birthright
citizenship has implications for
National Security because it says okay
if you're born here
you have a vested interest in the
country you get citizenship that creates
a tie if you end Birthright citizenship
for people born here you can create all
sorts of different security issues legal
gray areas raise questions about rights
and obligations of individuals within
the country it's extraordinarily
problematic in a number of different
ways now do we believe Trump will
actually do this on day one of his
presidency I don't know I mean I I
genuinely don't know Trump says a lot of
things he told us in August of 2020 that
we were two weeks away from receiving
his new health care plan
I'm still waiting for it I'm really
curious what would be in there maybe he
meant August of 2024 I don't know at
this point in time but Will trump
actually do it unclear would this be a
good idea no would it even be
constitutional probably not did you know
that half of Americans are deficient in
vitamins A and C as well as magnesium if
you keep your diet nutritionally
balanced all the time you can get
everything you need but half of
Americans don't and it can really impact
how you feel our sponsor athletic greens
makes it super easy I mix one scoop of
ag1 from athletic greens into water it
tastes great I get all of the high
quality vitamins and minerals I need
from Whole Food sourced ingredients I
don't have to Fumble around with bottles
capsules individual vitamins and things
like that I just don't have the time you
should see what's going on at my house
ag1 simplifies everything I'm covering
my nutritional basis for the entire day
okay
super easy easy to stick to as well and
dramatically more cost effective than
getting all of these different vitamin
supplements go to athletic greens.com
Pacman for a free year supply of vitamin
D I've talked about vitamin D many times
plus five free ag1 travel packs the link
is down below